When it comes to giving holiday gifts, it’s
the thought that counts, right?
WRONG.
YOUR RELATIONSHIP IS ON THE LINE.
DO NOT SCREW THIS UP.
Hey holiday shoppers, Chastity here filling
in for DNews.
Shopping for holiday gifts is an unavoidable
pain that we endure year after year.
Fighting through traffic to get to the malls.
Fighting at the malls to get parking.
Long lines, limited budgets, high stress.
Online shopping has made that process a bit
easier, but thinking of the perfect gift is
still the biggest challenge of all.
According to science, it’s NOT just the
thought that counts.
Studies show that giving bad gifts COULD potentially
hurt your relationships.
So, if you’re one of the many last minute
shoppers out there, there’s a lot more on
the line than you think.
A 2012 study in the Journal of Experimental
Psychology: General, found that the thought
only counts under specific conditions.
At first, when participants thought about
receiving a gift they liked, the thought didn’t
count.
The amount of thought they believed givers
put into it was not correlated with their
perception of the gift.
Then, participants thought about times they
received a bad gift.
In this case, the givers’ thought process
DID count, and WAS correlated with the evaluation
of the gift.
The receivers were triggered by the bad gift
to think about the givers’ intentions.
Probably along the lines of, “What the hell
were they thinking?
Why would I want SAND ART?”
Hot tip - NO ONE wants sand art.
A study in the Journal of Personality and
Social Psychology looks at close relationships.
The researchers argue that people are happiest
in their relationships when they believe they
have found someone who understands them and
shares their experiences.
So good gifts signify similarity in a relationship,
which does little for the relationship itself.
Bad gifts, however, could cause people to
question their similarity, which damages the
relationship.
A 2011 study in the Journal of Experimental
Social Psychology, found that people appreciate
the gifts they explicitly request more than
those they do not.
We want what we ask for, plain and simple.
Yet as gift givers, we don’t understand
that - we assume both solicited and unsolicited
gifts are equally appreciated.
So if your loved one gives you the ol’ “Oh
I dunno, surprise me!”...DON’T.
Think about that year your aunt got you that
shake weight.
Or that gift card from your friend for the
chain restaurant you hate that’s STILL in
your wallet.
Instead, ask for an idea of what they might
want.
Get something you know they’ll like, especially
if you want to be closer with them.
And do not, I repeat, do not re-gift something
you got from someone else.
Don’t be that guy.
They will find out.
Tell us about your gift exchanging nightmares
in the comments below, and don’t forget
to subscribe for more DNews.
I’m Chastity and I’ll see you next time.
Happy Holidays!